-Our next guest can be
seen at Zanies in Nashville
December 28th.
Please welcome
the very funny Jay Jurden!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hey, y'all.
I'm...pretty dumb.
Yeah.
No, don't let
this turtleneck fool you.
I can come out here
and pretend like I know stuff,
but when I go home,
I'm definitely gonna be like,
"Oh, there's a 'U'
in 'camouflage'?"
Doing a good job of hiding.
Like, that's...
Speaking of being dumb,
I recently got married!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
Alright. Yeah.
To a dude.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, okay.
Yeah! Alright!
I saw some people stop clapping.
Listen, I love homophobia.
It keeps me on my toes.
Now, I know there are
some old-fashioned people here,
some people here
who believe marriage is
strictly between a man, a woman,
and eventually
a much younger woman.
A much younger woman who
happened to get
this executive-assistant
position with no experience.
All I'm saying is, I don't think
Tasha "knows Excel."
[ Applause ]
Me and my husband --
we got married in New York City,
but we wanted to have
a traditional
Southern gay wedding.
So we had a cake.
We had a deejay.
We had protesters.
And, y'all, they were
making some good points.
One of the signs said,
"This is a choice."
I was like, "Of course
we have vegan options.
Come on, man."
Here's what they don't tell you.
When you get married
as a man to another man,
you spend most of
your wedding day
introducing gay men
who live in New York City
to other gay men
they have already slept with.
So most of my wedding day,
I was stuck saying stuff like,
"Well, Benjamin, you know Todd."
Shane, you know Todd."
Michael, you know Todd.
Wait a second.
Does everyone know Todd?"
And then my husband was like,
"Jay, do you know Todd?"
And I was like, "Ooh!
I do."
And then -- and then
I had to remind him.
I said, "No, baby.
We know Todd."
And he was like,
"Oh, that's Todd?
I didn't recognize him
standing up."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm surprised y'all
let me get away with that one.
We had a fun officiant
at our wedding.
Our wedding officiant, Dani,
with an "I," she was the best.
She walked in.
She was like, "Hey, y'all.
We are gathered here today in
front of friends, family, God.
I'm kidding. He ain't watching.
Let's turn up."
And I was like, "Let's go!"
Now, something interesting
just happened.
When I said
I was married to a dude,
I heard a bunch of "whoos!"
And that let me know it's a lot
of straight women here.
Straight girls, I love y'all.
We go way back.
Middle school.
Now...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Straight women,
are y'all doing okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright.
Then why y'all
love dating ugly dudes?
What is the reasoning?
Do you know that being straight
doesn't have to be a dare?
You can enjoy it?
And then y'all come up to me
after the show
and say stuff like,
"Well, Jay, just so you know,
I happen to like
my men a little ugly.
Right, babe?"
And this poor guy is like,
"You hear that?
She only said 'a little.'"
Y'all will brag to me
about your ugly man.
You'll be like,
"Well, Jay, just so you know,
me and my ugly man --
we're flying to Paris."
I'm like, "Yeah, he's got to get
back to Notre Dame.
Those bells aren't gonna
ring themselves."
Of course,
I don't mean anyone here.
Every straight guy here is a 10.
If you don't believe me,
I'll kiss you on the way out.
That goes for you too, Jimmy.
I like the beard.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But, seriously,
one of my friends --
he's an old-school comedian.
What's the word for that?
He's a misogynist.
And he said...
He said, "Jay, these women
date these ugly men
just so they can
get their money."
And I was like, "Yeah,
I know ugly men have money.
I've been on a boat before."
Someone out there is like,
"Wait, I have a boat."
I'm not talking about you.
You're gorgeous.
Seriously, do you think
the ugly community
is going to cancel me
for that joke?
Do you think the ugly community
is going to come for me?
As long as they don't do it
in person. Yuck!
No, everyone right now is so
obsessed with cancel culture.
Everyone's worried about
cancel culture.
Everyone except for me.
Because do you understand how
hard it would be to cancel...
me?
Come on, y'all.
I'm black. I'm queer.
I'm left-handed.
There are...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...lots of words I can say.
Alright, thank y'all so much.
I've been Jay Jurden.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You're left-handed?
You're left-handed?
-Yeah, I am.
[ Both laugh ]
-Jay Jurden! Jay Jurden!
Come on!
He'll be at Zanies in Nashville.
I love Zanies.
In Nashville December 28th.
My thanks to Kevin Bacon,
Theo James,
Old 97's, Jay Jurden once again!
He's left-handed, folks.